in top gun maverick you're gonna see
real actors in the cockpit
and the full capability of the airplane
when you're watching the movie
when you get up there you have a new
respect for fighter pilots
there's nothing like it
that's a kill
when i first found out that we had to be
in jets
i was excited
baby
[Music]
i didn't expect anything less because
it's tom cruise he does all of his
stunts so i expected us to have to do it
too
but when it became real like oh
i don't want to do this anymore
oh okay one of my favorite analogies
that some of the top gun pilots have
it's like being strapped on to a dragon
i told everyone if you're gonna take
this role part of it is being in that
f-18 i don't know how to do it any other
way
being in an f-18 is
unreal
there's gonna be a lot of stuff that
people see and go no way they really did
that
and we really did that
tom said i need this to happen at 30
feet above the ground
he was doing 480 knots basically a 500
mile an hour race car
i've been doing this in these airplanes
for a really long time and i watch that
and i go wow that's fantastic i wanted
to celebrate the fighter pilot watching
them explore what we do
it's breathtaking
there's nothing like it
the navy the top gun team oh they're
amazing
[Music]
[Music]
you